this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks so much Steven thanks so much for
having me here it's really a pleasure to
be out here so as Steve said my
background is in geography so I tend to
you know be interested in something like
this that you see in the background
slide here this is an invasion of Sahara
mustard and the Mojave Desert out in the
western US but I rarely get the chance
to actually see any of these things in
the field because for the most part what
I do is use data that other people have
collected from the field to try to
understand stuff about spatial
distributions of either distributions or
abundance of species
so what biogeography is and that was
kind of an introduction to it but
biogeography is basically trying to use
the distributions of species to learn
something more about the biology of
those species about the ecology how
those species interact with native
communities if we're talking about an
invasive species like oriental
bittersweet evolution of those species
how those species have interacted over
larger time or adaptations to global
change so we're really saying alright
people have gone out and collected all
of these locations where we know that
species exist and what can that
information tell us about in this case
invasion risk of a species and there is
an assumption in biogeography and
particularly when we're talking about
regional scale but this affects
landscape scale models as well but
basically the distribution of this
species whatever the species is that
you're seeing over here is a reasonable
approximation of where that species
could be so basically where the suitable
climate is for that species is described
pretty well by where that species is
right now and that assumption that the
distribution of a species is a good
approximation of where that species
could be of suitable climate for that
species has been used for a number of
different papers these ones are you know
now probably classic papers when you're
talking about global change and species
movement and species distributions to
it's things like what species are likely
to go extinct associated with climate
change right there they're here now but
but under warming temperatures and
altered precipitation the richness or
diversity of species that any one of
these red spots could decrease because
you know because we know what their
ranges are now and you know or we're
predicting what their ranges might be in
the future that's been done in Europe
and Mexico globally this assumption of
the distributions of species are a good
approximation for suitable climate has
also been done for activities like
predicting or assigning conservation
priorities so you know where are the
species now and how does that what does
that tell us about where they could be
where lots of them are likely to overlap
and these kind of red and yellow areas
it's also been done so this is an
example that that I've done on modeling
potential for invasion with climate
change so in this case you've got kudzu
which is really about us down in the
southeast us right you can see the end
of that car this is actually a house
under air rights they're not a place
that you want to live if you've got kids
you in your backyard and this is just an
example showing expansion of kids you up
into the Northeast into New York and in
Massachusetts where I'm from by the end
of this century with climate change but
again all of these are based on this
assumption that distribution is a good
approximation of suitable climate and so
what I want to do in you know I'm going
to get a little wonky here I think into
the biogeography side of things but but
holding to that application of really
what all of this is trying to get at is
how much are we going to trust and in
what cases should we be trusting spatial
models to really inform what we're doing
on the ground are monitoring our
management everything else so I'm going
to look at two different questions today
the first one is a question of
comparative equilibrium so how how much
are those species distributions
approximating climate for native versus
non-native plants and then we're going
to explore the native plants a little
bit further in the second half and ask
whether native plant range
are really describing their climatic
tolerance um and so the to start on that
first one the equilibrium assumption and
this is really fundamental to a lot of
biogeography equilibrium assumption says
going back to Hutchinson's paper of 1957
species is in equilibrium with its
environment when its present basically
everywhere that it could be all of the
suitable areas but not present or absent
and all of the areas that are unsuitable
for that species right and so if we're
doing any kind of model based on whether
it's climatic suitability or other you
know suitability of the soils or other
features of a landscape for a species
we're assuming that this is true for
that species that it is present where it
could be present and absent where it
cannot be present but the problem with
any kind of distribution model is that
we could always be missing something
right
so if our model is based on all of these
gray points in here and we're missing
these you know green points of out over
here then the model that we're gonna
create is not going to be an accurate
representation of the temperature and
precipitation conditions that this
species could exist in right so why
might be you mean we'd be missing the
species out here well it could be
because we just didn't survey that area
we're missing a couple of points that
the species actually exists in it could
be that it's some sort of you know an
invasive species that started out over
here and just hasn't expanded those
areas yet it could be that these
temperature and precipitation conditions
don't currently exist on our landscape
but they might under future climate
conditions and so how do we deal with
those kind of challenges in the modeling
framework so for invasive species in
particular this assumption of
equilibrium the assumption that a
species is describing its full niche its
full area that it could that it could
particularly persist in is fundamentally
flawed for an invasive species right
because we know that invasive species
are spreading across landscapes they're
spreading across regions this is an
example of the
kudzu beetle this guy over here which
does in fact eat kudzu I'm told but it
also eats soybeans so that's the
drawback of why we're concerned about
this particular pest and this is just
the spread between 2009 and 2012 right
so really broad scale spread of that
particular pest if you only considered
the distribution of where it was in the
early stage of an infestation then you
probably be missing a large scale and in
fact even out to 2012 is probably
missing to a large degree where that
species could specifically exist so what
we're gonna do is is try to tackle this
question for invasive plants
specifically so we're asking how bad is
this equilibrium assumption how far off
are we in general when we're talking
about invasive plants from equilibrium
with the with the environment and this
is from a paper published almost two
years ago in global ecology and by a
geography if you're interested in the
more details but the way we wanted to go
about this is we know that there's never
any species that's going to be in
perfect equilibrium right there's always
going to be someplace that species
either wasn't able to get to or that
space high matically doesn't exist yet
or something like that so there's no way
that we can define this perfect
equilibrium but what we can do is we can
compare native and invasive species and
say relative to each other how far off
or invasive species right how much
should we be worried about missing
something in terms of our modeling of
invasive plants and so here's our
hypothesis our hypothesis is that for a
native plant they have had lots and lots
of time you know so if we you know even
just going back to the last glacial
maximum we say 20,000 plus years for
these species to move around and other
places that were less affected by
glaciation you've got way more time for
them to move around and so for a given
number of occurrences we would expect
that those species of native species
would be more widely distributed and
that they would also have a larger
modeled potential range based on that
broad distribution and contrasts
we might hypothesize that non-native
plants including invasive plants would
have a much smaller distribution
relative with the same number of
occurrences and a smaller modeled
potential range and that those two
things we could sort of say all right
that also affects the longitudinal and
latitudinal extent of those species that
that your native species you would
expect to be more widespread and your
and your non-native species so this is
just a way of presenting that previous
graph in terms of some line graphs and
of course as you increase the number of
occurrences you would expect both of
these things to go up in terms of your
overall potential range but we would
expect that the native species would be
higher overall than than the non natives
so how did we test this we went about
testing this using all of the plants
that we could find within the
continental US so we downloaded the
whole list of plants from the USDA
plants database that's actually closer
to about 20,000 species that you find
within the continental US
the USDA breaks those into native
species endemic species alien so these
are non-native species and then from the
alien ones we also separated out the
invasive species based on ones that are
either noxious weeds or identified as
invasive plants on invasive plant atlas
of the US and endemics USDA doesn't
actually break that down so endemics we
got from another database and separated
those out as well in case something
interesting was happening and then we
looked at so we cross-reference that
database against all of the herbarium
records that are available in this
global biodiversity information facility
repository for global or barium records
so lots of states regions are putting
their data into that repository these
are where the plants have actually been
found and someone has a geographical
latitude longitude record of where those
species came from and that ended up with
our 13 585 total species that actually
had
enough records in the global
biodiversity information facility
database that we could create a
reasonable model based on and so the
analysis of this was that we took a
particular species so all these circles
are the location of that particular
species we have a pretty simple PCA
based model to look at potential range
of those species which is showing up in
here in this kind of late yellow color
and we said potential range is just a
count of all of these pixels these
yellow areas of where that species could
potentially be located and then we
looked at one other thing we looked at
range infilling which is basically the
ratio of where all of these species are
present to all of these areas where it
could be present because we thought well
we're thinking about invasive species in
particular can we say something about
more invasion likely on the horizon
associated with where it is relative to
where it could be so just to go back to
that hypothesis again so look first at
latitudinal and longitudinal ranges so
our prediction again is that our native
species both native and endemic species
together should be more widespread
they've had way more time you know to
spread across landscapes and regions in
which they could have climatic
suitability than our relatively recently
introduced invasive and alien species so
there's our prediction and here's our
result exactly the opposite of what we
predicted so whereas we thought our
natives and endemics or I guess I should
say that anytime you read biogeography
literature related to invasive species
you always have this kind of clause at
the beginning that says oh we know that
invasive species are not at equilibrium
so this is probably under prediction so
what we're seeing is actually the exact
opposite that it's our natives and
endemic species that are much more
narrowly distributed both longitudinally
and latitudinal II not a significant
difference between our invasives and our
aliens or between our natives and
endemics
between the two groups a very strong and
significant difference that second
hypothesis you guys could probably
figure out where we're going on this one
that the potential range then of native
species would be greater on average than
non-native species note we find exactly
the opposite that as you have increasing
occurrences of either non native or
native species you're seeing this
increase in potential range that you
might expect but consistently it's the
non-native species and non-natives and
the invasives that are higher up in
terms of the modeled potential range
then our native plants are and so we're
fundamentally rejecting this hypothesis
or this sort of framing that it's
actually that non native plants are
really not at equilibrium with climate
in fact what we're seeing is compared to
native plants arguably it's the
non-native plants that are closer to
climatic equilibrium the non-native
plants that are probably creating better
models of distribution of risk of rain
shifts associated with with climate
change and so why is that okay so
probably the reason is because we are
really good at introducing invasive
plants right most of we know that most
of the population of invasive plants in
the u.s. six at least 60% probably more
than that
are introduced as ornamental plants
certainly a much higher proportion of
that for our non-native non invasive
plants are introduced as ornamentals and
so here's an example of this is a
centaurea species so bachelor button
bachelors button this is declared as a
noxious weed and the southeast part of
the US I think in Tennessee but is
obviously really widespread introduced
and planted in our gardens across the US
and its potential range as you can see
from that light yellow really really
broad because it's inhabiting all of
these different climate conditions can
compare that so here's your bachelor
button with 458 occurrences this species
is getting pretty much
the entire us it takes almost double
that number of occurrences for the
average native species to get even close
to that and it's not even fully getting
there in terms of the full range so even
our most common native species are still
showing much more of this clumping
bunching than our kind of average
non-native or invasive oops so range
filling was that other question okay and
you guys can probably guess based on the
way these these graphs look range in
filling is that question of how much
more space is there to go how much more
can the species extend so here's our
native species you can see that there is
still a fair bit of of this late yellow
space of within its potential range but
for the invasive species there's tons of
that light yellow potential range so if
we look at range in filling we're seeing
that that the native species are much
more kind of clumped together and have
infilled within their ranges whereas the
invasive species not at all
and so for the average invasive plant
the average invasive plant is filling in
only half as much of its potential range
relative to the average native species
right so if we think that it your
average invasive plant is going to
behave like your average native plant
then that means that we are currently
only about halfway there in terms of the
amount of spread within landscapes or
within those regions that these plants
could potentially do so here's an
example this is a bamboo species where
you know care all of the locations where
this bamboo has been introduced and we
know and in fact this is up into New
Jersey as well and there are a bunch of
you know pictures of people already
getting angry at their neighbors for
planting bamboo that's coming into their
into their yards so we know that that
these species are likely to this guy up
here in New Jersey was pretty angry
about his neighbors bamboo and here
we've got some of you know natural
spaces and open spaces that are already
being taken over by that species which
is an ornamental plant that's widely
widely planted across
um so that tells us which is really from
a biogeography perspective this is
really interesting because because it
tells us kind of two things one it tells
us that actually a lot of our risk
assessments for invasive plants relative
to climate and relative to climate
change are probably pretty good or at
least pretty good relative to natives
but it also tells us that the natives
are projections relative to climate
change might be a little bit sketchy
right because the natives are are not
apparently distributed and and
facilitated by us in terms of being
introduced in all of these places so for
invasive plants unlike the what we had
expected the invasive plants are
actually very widespread it could be
considered much closer to this climatic
equilibrium than the native plants are
but we also see that there is really low
range filling associated with invasive
plants and so there's probably a lot
more of these landscape scale invasions
that we should expect on the horizon as
if we don't have enough data to deal
with great so that was the first
question so I kind of alluded to the
second question when I said that the the
equilibrium analysis that we did left
this kind of question about what's going
on with native species right if we start
out with this framing that says invasive
species are the ones that are not at
equilibrium and now we're saying well
actually it looks like it's native
species that are less like equilibrium
that raises the question of well how
well our native species doing how well
our plants ranges within their native
native ranges describing so sort of
going after that same question but their
climatic tolerance or their their
equilibrium in that case with climate
and there are some there have been there
is ongoing kind of large-scale
discussion of this question both within
well particularly within the invasive
plant literature this is a paper from I
think 2011 where what they were looking
at was basically you have a bunch of
issues that come from Europe and they're
moving to North America North America to
Europe is in this one and Europe to
North America is in this one and
basically the blue on here are areas
that are where that species is
inhabiting the same climate space both
in Europe and in North America so these
guys are mostly blue mostly blue on both
of these like a little bit of area where
the species is expanding its climatic
niche basically as it moves from one
continent to another but they're their
underlying statement here was that it's
pretty rare for a species to change its
climate space basically you know if
you've got a species in Europe and it's
within this particular temperature and
precipitation regime you move it to
North America for the most part it's
going to be within the same temperature
and precipitation regime and that would
suggest if that's the case for invasive
species that suggests that for most
species you know like if you've got a
given temperature and climatic regime
and that's probably what that species
can persist under right so this is
arguing for equilibrium or close to
equilibrium for these range shifting
plants there is another study that was
published only a couple years after that
they came to basically the exact
opposite conclusion but also looked for
species that were native to Europe and
shifting into North America and
basically in this case all of the orange
areas are ones where there was this
climatic niche expansion and that's most
of North America had this niche
expansion so these two papers are
basically arguing the exact opposite
conclusions with this you know what
seemingly similar set of species that
are moving from Europe to North America
and vice-versa so so that is sort of
fundamental to this this question as
well of well how much are native species
generally in equilibrium with climate
conditions and this is a paper that was
published about a year ago if you guys
want more of the details was actually
our first author and this was a UMass
undergraduate student who compiled all
of the data for this
so here's our hypothesis our hypothesis
is we're just gonna look at species that
are native to the US and this species
for example if Texas said we're gonna
assume that that has a particular
climatic tolerance associated that can
be described based on its native range
and then if that species of Texas says
we're moved over to Nevada or California
that it would be within the same
climatic conditions as are found in its
native range so here we are looking
specifically at species that are native
to the US so described by this biota of
North America program but also have
advent of range so basically a
non-native range within the US as well
these are almost all exclusively species
that are within the ornamental plant
industry so they are cultivated species
that have been taken from parts of the
US and planted elsewhere in the US and
so what we did was we looked for all of
the occurrence data that we could find
within both global biodiversity
information facility is one source we
also because not all herb area are up to
date in terms of reporting there looked
at a whole bunch of different regional
orb area for any occurrence data that we
can find in both the native range as
well as this advent of introduced range
and we know the advent of range because
the biota of North America program tells
us where its native range is and then we
compare the climate conditions between
those two locations so are the areas
where it's been introduced outside of
its native range under similar climate
conditions to the ones where its native
so here's an example of a species this
is a China this virginica sits a white
fringe tree or something like that
so what you see on this map are the
light blue areas are all of the counties
that this tree is native to all across
the southeast and then we have all of
the occurrence locations that we have in
the dark blue dots as well as the red
dots the dark blue dots are the ones
where
the occurrence of that species is within
its native range and the red dots are
the ones where the appearance is outside
of its native range including up in New
York and Massachusetts and Connecticut
stuff like that and also including up
here in the Pacific Northwest where that
species has been introduced and so
here's what we find with that particular
species which probably doesn't surprise
you too much looking at this map we know
that the conditions in New York and
Connecticut and Massachusetts are pretty
different from you know the climate
conditions down here that generally what
we see for this particular species is
that it can it is persisting in these
areas where it's been introduced in
areas that are cooler than its native
range and also slightly drier so you
know a couple of points in areas that
are slightly drier than its native range
so the Reds on here are all of those
advent of the introduce points in the
blue on here are all of the native
points and you can see that there's also
plenty of overlap so there are lots of
climate conditions and the advent of
range that are well represented within
the native range but definitely a little
bit cooler a little bit drier on here so
how does that compare to the overall
number of species so remember we had 144
species that we were working with 90 of
those showed lower precipitation in the
areas where they were introduced
relative to their native range and the
median decrease I don't know what the
right word is the median amount of
precipitation lower than its native
range was 23 centimeters which is pretty
substantive I've done a lot of work in
the western US and there are a lot of
places that barely get 23 centimeters of
rain so that's pretty substantive and 90
out of 144 species are showing that
expansion of drought tolerance we're
also seeing 56 of the species 56 of our
hundred and forty-four showed an
expansion of heat tolerance with the
median amount being one point two
degrees C warmer part of the reason for
there aren't super number of species
that are that are going in this
direction may just be
geography of the US that there's a lot
more space as you go for their north and
then going south if you look at cold
tolerance so we had 80 out of a hundred
and forty four species showed an
expansion of cold tolerance and a median
of 2.9 degrees C different in terms of
that climatic range that could be
described and then that last piece was
that we also modeled the potential range
of all of these species right so here's
for that one particular species so China
this Inachus the blue is its potential
range based on just its native range and
the red is its potential range based on
the native plus the advent of range
right so you see in that case we're
getting divided by it up into its New
England and further north from that that
native Southeast range so that's one
species on average 128 of our 144
species showed an expansion of of their
potential range when you considered both
the native and the advent of points the
median amount of expansion was 35
percent or 700,000 square kilometers
which I learned last night is about five
times the size of the state of New York
so that's a pretty big area if you're
thinking about you know okay we want to
understand how species are likely to
move with climate change and what their
current range is and we're missing five
New York states then and that's a that's
a pretty big area that that were
underestimated currently so this
hypothesis that we started out with that
advent of locations of that species are
good are going to be really similar to
the climate space where they started out
is not supportive and not supported that
in fact in fact we're seeing yacht's
right so we're trying to dig a little
bit into this well what sort of species
are actually expanding the most in terms
of their climate space so he said well
maybe if they have more points than the
advent of range that's going to be those
are the species if they've got water
introductions maybe it'll have this
larger range size expansion and we don't
see that at all there's just kind of a
big clump there so it doesn't matter how
many times
you've been introduced but what does
seem to matter is the size of your
native range so for species that had
relatively small areas to begin with as
you start introducing points outside of
there we very rapidly get you know a big
shift in climate space and a much larger
predicted range size as you start adding
more advent of locations so these
species with small native ranges appear
to be less limited by climate that is
climate you know we can make a really
nice model of climate describing their
range but it's not actually climate it's
limiting those grant the ranges of those
narrow range species and just to go back
to this comparison early on that initial
framing right where you know early in
saks a huge amount of niche expansion
when you move from north america to the
US and petit-pierre say no niche
expansion when you move from Europe to
the US when you actually plot those
species together relative to what their
native range size is you see a very
similar pattern if you like the
petit-pierre study had a really large
like you were really wide spread really
species all across Europe to begin with
you get introduced to North America
you're not expanding much because you're
all over the place to begin with in
Europe but in the early in saks paper
they were looking at a lot of species
that were much narrow had much narrower
ranges in Europe and so they had a lot
more space to expand and climate space
that they were expanding into when they
got to the US so if I tell this
basically is when we go back to these
you know fundamental concerns and
certainly this is a fundamental concern
when we're talking about climate change
of what's gonna happen to rare species
you know what's happening to these you
know really narrow range species this
you know this analysis in my and my
current thinking on this is that well
we've done a lot of climate modeling and
constructed all of these things for
these really small range species but it
may actually
be they climate is not what's important
for the ranges of those species so that
doesn't mean that they're not still
threatened by climate change if your
narrow range to begin with you've got a
lot of other problems going on too and
the climate change may very well affect
those species in place to a large degree
but what it doesn't necessarily mean and
what you know these guys had said
previously doesn't necessarily mean that
those species cannot move into a new
climate conditions or expand into into
other parts so our conclusions from this
or that the the native range is
basically especially small range native
species are not doing a good job of
describing climate tolerance or the
native plant pool at least and this may
be a little bit of a silver lining in
terms of projections of risk climate
changed that many of these small range
species if we were to start considering
tools like assisted migration or moving
some of these species in advance of
climate change that those may well be
effective mechanisms currently even if a
distribution model or the geography of
its current location would not suggest
that it can establish and persist beyond
where it currently does so these are
just that to go back to the conclusions
of these two studies that spatial
modeling anytime you guys look at a bio
Geographic model any kind any time you
look at a landscape ecology model that's
based on the distribution of species
those are assuming the distribution of
that species is reflecting the habitat
of that species and so I hope that I've
told you know like I hope that I haven't
convinced you the distribution modeling
is proud because there are definitely
some good examples to use it for but
what I but I what I want to convince
your today is just that there's more
nuance to understanding when we should
really believe the models and when we
should you know kind of raise an eyebrow
and say well you know are you sure that
that that model is is representative of
the species that I you know only know
and
or 20 or something like that so thanks
so much yeah so this is a real challenge
in terms of just the data that exists
out there right so anytime that you're
dealing with a spatial model for the
most part the underlying data are just
points in space and those points could
be occurrences they could be absences
they could have some abundance
information in them but that's that's
fairly rare there are a lot of folks who
are really trying to get after building
more spatial demographic models
understanding interactions between
predator prey or insect inside the plant
and the challenge about is just like how
do you get both spatial and demographic
data of multiple species together and
you know I think it's I think it's
coming it's just it's just that we need
to really focus our data compilation and
collection in that direction that you
yeah and I mean the other challenges
that you end up doing it for you know a
couple of specific species some of the
great things about just spatial modeling
generally is that you can do it for lots
of different species and try to see if
consistent trends emerge such that you
can say something you know something
relevant
yeah thanks very much I just a question
about your native versus attentive
distinction so climate is changing did
you look at all the data newer with a
modified climate compared to the native
data which tend to be that's a really
good point
the other question with that paper also
is we don't necessarily know that those
species are established we we assume
that they are because they're in
herbarium records and herbarium records
generally go for areas that are
relatively natural and not like in the
watered you know fields or something
like that I don't I don't know that we
look specifically of for dates on a lot
of those records a lot of the herbarium
records that we have are relatively new
so there are definitely some that go
back to the 60s 70s or earlier but the
big chunk when you actually look at them
are like from the 90s and later on so I
think relative to current climate change
that's probably a time period when we
say it's been relatively similar for the
last 20 or 30 years when most of those
points are coming from but that's a
really good question in comparing the
native species within they occur to me
that introduced species tend to be
introduced because they are clearly the
ornamentals are introduced because they
have a lot
climatic elements you know it gives they
only live in Florida and their trunk
license and exclusively you know the
conduction he's sold all over the United
States so there's there's a vector and
the other is related is that the
introduced species going to be
disturbance Orion they're they're they
all mister
be able to run side native species are
largely things that existed in
undisturbed habitats and so we go around
astronomy habitats and you get these
things existing in a lot of different
places whereas the natives well I think
that's a really good hypothesis right
you know like but it's one that hasn't
necessarily been tested for a lot of the
native species just because we haven't
widely introduced tons of these native
species all across you know different
parts of the US I mean I agree with you
I think that's probably going to be true
that your invasives and your meteor
species or disturbance specialists and
that your native species generally or
not but I don't know that you know I
don't know that we've actually done a
full-scale test to really nail down you
know how different how and the yeah your
first part definitely you know the
characteristics that we love for
ornamental plants that they're you know
wide climatic tolerance and they grow
fast and you know like produce lots of
seeds and you know showy things and
stuff like that are exactly the kind of
things that we worry about in terms of
invasive plants so there is definitely a
lot of overlap between that selection
pressure coming in and what ends up
within the invasive plant population but
I really like your question of whether
you know how different they are from the
native populations in terms of that yeah
in terms of the the range in filling in
the tenpin creases they're kind of
operating in a persecution scale as is
biome scale right so we think about
across the landscape we don't see a ton
variation
in temperature it's what's driving the
variation of that spatial scale almost
species abundance we think I think
fantastic racial cleansing the wheel
yeah so what do I mean the null
hypothesis all popular I guess we could
go after that one you know disturbance
certainly affects them micro habitats
like soil quality is and you know
abiotic local things you know water
availability aspects and slope and stuff
like that
presumably biotic resistance has
something to do with not necessarily the
distribution of species but certainly
the local abundance of species so the
diversity or traits of your native
community might affect those are those
are the things that I think about I
don't know and actually Steve and I were
talking about this this morning is like
whether there are data sets out there
and trying to go after data sets that
could actually try to answer those
questions spatially the minds with face
experiments we see poison ivy Prince
outside of the rain easily no poison ivy
decided tonight so clearly if you don't
bility to is limiting growth that I'm
certainly not even yeseo to certain day
for invasive plants there's consistent
trends of co2 facilitating invasive more
so than it does native plants a lot of
that I think it's just that going back
to like the definition of meatiness of
you know fast-growing species like more
resources and so absolutely co2 co2 is
is a tricky one spatially though because
you know like it's it's for the most
part everywhere I think that's a really
fascinating question I have never done
any work on native range as well as non
native range of invasive plants but
there are a lot of people who are trying
to look at those questions of you know
is it one of the things that I think is
most fascinating about that is actually
the information about the evolutionary
history of those species within their
native range and are there places on
earth just bio geographically that kind
of like breed and basis just because
they're like you know more competition
longer evolutionary history more enemies
that you could potentially be released
from those kind of things you know there
are a couple of studies of that for you
know like East Asian species being
introduced to the Northeast is one
example and African grasses that are
fire-prone being introduced to a variety
of continents and perpetuating price
cycles there is another example of that
so it's a really neat question but I I
don't know anything which are based on
observational data you're commenting
sort of on the organisms that had a
smaller range but doesn't this apply
everything that begins observational do
dress just a smaller range alike so the
assumption of people living this one we
have to make
[Music]
so Lance or not people over to begin
with yeah definitely well but then I
think that what what these studies have
shown to me is that if you're a
widespread plant that's not the case
like the widespread plants actually it
is probably a pretty good assumption to
say like this is that it's close to
equilibrium so it's great for me it's
like this narrow range versus wide range
kind of thing that I would be most I
would be more skeptical of narrow range
models and I guess the the intriguing
part for me just bio geographically is
to try to figure out like more things
like that you know like are there
particular cases when we should trust
the models more or trust the models less
because that will certainly lead us to
better monitoring and better management
later on you think about fair right
there there applause so so you know it
seems like there's yeah I mean really do
spatial models on bears use very
different methods than plans but part of
that is also because you have you also
have absence data and you can do you
know like you know things you know
multiple times through and that's why
we've been trying to go after abundance
information more and more because at
least doesn't necessarily give us
absence data but at least it gives us
more insight into like here's actually
invasive versus there it's just like
there is a plant one fun question see
and ideas being a
or is a question for five dated question
whether it is data he where a fetus or
what it is them key strategies to
implement to help better answer these
questions
so maybe abundance yeah we so that's
that's great that you're asking a
question we actually been trying to to
put together some like recommendations
for the collection of invasive plant
abundance so there's fantastic work
going on through like IMAP invasives in
the state of New York through a lot of
the different state level organizations
but those tend to be just occurrences
and so we don't have absences we don't
have any sense of how bad the
infestation is or the areal extent of
the infestation so the two main things
that I would love to have for plants are
an estimate of percent cover and an
estimate of the area of infestation and
those could be completely like just you
know I don't know twenty percent cover
there's a fair bit of it here kind of
thing and about the size of this room
that would be totally fine for a lot of
the modeling stuff that we're trying to
do but we have also been looking through
there is a citizen science and
management database called ed maps and
we've been looking through that larger
database to try to see what people are
doing when they're reporting abundance
and those tend to be kind of ranges four
percent covered or so like less than one
percent went to five five to something
ten twenty twenty-five pickier and
pickier number there are greater than
that and those also work really well
when when we can't because because we
can't ask you know most managers to go
out and start running like six transects
you know across the landscape but you
know a thousand points but they're going
to be at a thousand points they could
probably say you know that's about 5%
cover or something in these areas and
that information gives us a lot a lot of
power - thanks for asking
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu